ce point des mégapoles américaine aux
petites communautés d'amérique du sud
ailleurs dans le monde comme au canada
près de 3,3 que votre la carte grâce des
maires de partout dans le monde pour
faire la différence mais les villes
peuvent être vraiment influencer les
choses et world
à victoriaville on a été parmi les
premiers à prendre le virage vert il y a
déjà une trentaine d'années
directeur général de la ville conduit
une voiture électrique comme un nombre
grandissant d'employés municipaux
il nous fait visiter ce matin et l'éco
parc industriel récemment mises en place
par la municipalité
confronté par le même des gens
d'affaires oscille de vie qui nous
faisait ne saurait quoi la prochaine
étape une solution
hubert blier a été le premier ainsi
installé son entreprise de
couvre-planchers avait besoin d espace
pour croître
souvent pense que ce est réservé aux
plus grandes entreprises même les
petites entreprises
on a une responsabilité avoir au niveau
de l'environnement et de l'écologie
contrairement à la pratique le terrain
où il a construit son bâtiment n'a pas
été rasés on a plutôt cherché à en
préserver la végétation le chauffage de
son entrepôt provient de panneaux
solaires installés sur le toit de
l'édifice en chapeau et un rendre une
économie d'environ 3000 $ par année ce
qui est quand même important pour une
petite entreprise comme la nôtre attirer
des entreprises n'a pas été facile pour
la ville mais après un an de prospection
hubert blier devrait bientôt avoir de
nouveaux voisins qui on parle d'une
seule entreprise raisonnement est
implantée la vision c'est que au cours
des cinq prochaines années il rassemble
ce parc le soir ils le sont
partout sur le territoire de la ville on
multiplie les gestes dans les rues
commerciales
le stationnement est gratuit pour les
conducteurs de voitures électriques
plus la peine de nourrir les parcomètres
on a aussi installé plusieurs bornes de
recharge de la vérité c'est que les
villes ont un rôle de premier plan
un jour 75 % de l'activité économique
que l'activité qui peut avoir une
empreinte sur l'environnement se déroule
sur nos territoires urbains pour
encourager les citoyens soucieux de
faire leur part
la ville a aussi mis sur pied un
programme de construction et de
rénovation domiciliaire verte jusqu'à
présent plus de 600 citoyens en ont
bénéficié
on met sur des matériaux soient
recyclables ou qui ont une longue durée
de vie avec possiblement une deuxième
vie
philippe cantin a reçu 8000 dollars de
subventions pour la construction de sa
maison qui respecte toute une série de
critères environnementaux
on a pour la tôle parce que ça les
mesures et de vie beaucoup plus grande
que le bardo et aussi on peut lui donner
un peu le recycler ses coûts de
construction ont été un peu plus élevée
mais n'allez pas croire que philippe
cantin ne sait pas calculer
j'ai des coûts énergétiques moyens et
des coûts de maintenance moindre donc
mensuellement mekhout d'hypothèques wii
sont peu plus haut mais avec tout ce qui
me coûte moins cher ben on revient au
même prix qu'une maison staller mais il
n'ya pas que les citoyens qui économise
avec les mesures qu'elle a mise en place
six dernières années
la ville estime épargner tous les ans
plus d'un million de dollars elle a
aussi empêché les missions annuelles du
3700 tonnes de co2 économisées 134 mille
litres d'eau potable
c'est payant aujourd'hui de poser c'est
juste les économies d'énergie les
économies de rebut les économies d'eau
potable que l'on fait ça se traduit en
valeur économique partout dans le monde
on ne compte plus les villes qui
s'investissent pour la protection de
l'environnement et la lutte contre les
changements climatiques est satisfait
des tergiversations des gouvernements
centraux les maires prennent le
leadership
ils mettent
l'avant leurs propres solutions et
veulent maintenant participer aux
négociations internationales
à tel point que le secrétaire général de
l'onu ban ki-moon nommait l'an dernier
un ambassadeur pour les représenter en
la personne de l'ancien maire de new
york le milliardaire michael bloomberg
campeau et son conseiller principal
fargo 5 ans les grandes puissances ont
échoué à s'entendre lors de la
conférence de copenhague les villes ou
des idées qu'elles n'attendraient pas
les gouvernements centraux et elles ont
décidé d'agir
c'est donc par milliers que des merdes
un peu partout sur la planète se
rendront à paris début décembre
autant de maires réunis pour une
conférence internationale ce sera du
jamais vu une ville qui posent des
risques parce qu'aujourd'hui maintenant
qu'elles sont impliqués veut s'impliquer
tous les niveaux inclus au niveau des
négociations internationales révèle
avoir faire partie de cette communauté
sikh les mères se sentent interpellés au
premier chef
alors que les conséquences des
changements climatiques sont de plus en
plus manifeste que l'ouragan samedi a
frappé new york et le connecticut
c'est la ville de new york qui a écopé
lorsqu'une sécheresse a touché le brésil
c'est le maire de sao paulo qui a dû
ramasser les pots cassés d'arrêt de metz
mais dans un forum où la voix des
grandes puissances est prépondérante
les maires peuvent-ils réellement
inspiré faire la différence villes qui
participent et qui se sent impliqué dans
la négociation d'un traité comme celui
là va peut-être aussi est plus motivé
après à mettre en oeuvre ces
dispositions
en tout cas victoriaville on ne se pose
même plus la question
on se dit que la meilleure façon d'être
influents c'est encore là j on a les
outils on a les moyens de le faire et
d'agir alors autant en profiter
et puis en plus c'est c'est socialement
souhaitable environnementalement
nécessaires puis économiquement rentable
alors je vois pas pourquoi